you worked on practical magic
there's been a lot of talk about hbo max
doing like a reboot or reimagining i'm
not exactly what the right term is um
when did you hear about that and what
are your thoughts on hbo max taking a
crack at it
uh god bless them um i uh
you know practical magic uh is um
i have a nine-year-old and a
nine-year-old daughter and an
11 year old daughter in practical magic
is i think the
literally the only thing i've written
that they can watch
uh and uh even then they have to fast
forward to the scare
through the scary nicole parts um um
i uh it's funny
i love practical matters practical magic
for me is also a movie where there was a
different version
which it sort of
weirdly in the same context that we're
discussing sort of
how the world has been has become more
interested in
this range of dark and light in the same
narrative object which i think is more
recent
um you know or that you can have
significance
and depth and loss in
uh fantasy uh or science fiction in ways
that
are more nuanced so there is a cut of
practical magic
before reshoots um
that griffin put together which was
stunningly beautiful
it was more 50 50 between sandy and
nicole
and this haunting of nicole was the
counterpoint to this sort of emergence
of sandy it was more of a ghost story um
and uh it was really beautiful it was
weird you know griffin done as a
director
is wonderful because you can't quite
locate the object in genre
and uh and there was a version of that
which
at one point years later i tried to find
because i had it on videotape i was
calling griffin and
we were talking about it
it got caught up in that sort of
marketing thing at warner brothers and
moved forward so
in a way that i think didn't serve it
ultimately i i
fundamentally believe that if hbo max
takes it now and
are able to kind of play into the
darkness a little more
as well as the joy i think that that
will be great
it's i find it so interesting talking to
people about
films when you know you have this
completely different version
and it's for me with the advent of home
video
and with hbo max you would think that
you know
something that they could put on hbo max
would be the alternate cut
of practical magic that's like a great
thing that fans would want to tune in
for right and here's why they don't
at least up until now is because those
cuts are almost never finished
you know what so typically what happens
is you
screen these things where the visual
effects are still temp
you know you're testing them while
they're attempting the score is nothing
so that like for me the one great
version of this in my career
is i am legend where the my the version
that we wrote
the words that we made originally is
what's called the alternative cut
right but that and that's this weird
trick
where i can literally go no that's the
one we meant to make
that's the one we made later and you can
you know what i mean and you can but
almost every movie has that right uh or
a lot of them do
you know we hear about the snyder cut a
lot like there's so
that's so often the case is that you
sort of
run down a path and then you
you manage it towards the end and
sometimes for the exactly the right
reasons and sometimes for exactly the
wrong reasons right
the right reasons being creative
perseverance of the wrong reasons being
fear
um and how that broth informs the end of
a movie
um you know is significant and yes i
think it would be
amazing you know and somewhere in the
archives
are all the versions you're talking
about somebody would have to commit to
going back and having it be a project of
finishing them
but i think people would actually love
them